"A Brief History of Modularity"
Ashley Williams
>> Hi, everyone!
Okay.
I'm feeling the excitement here.
We're in the last track.
We have three more talks to go before we start
partying.
So our next speaker is Ashley.
She is from New York City.
This is the New York City track.
We have four speakers from New York.
So she works at npm, AKA Wombat Development
Union.
You'll have to ask her about that later.
She loves explaining it.
So she was heavily featured in the introduction
video, actually, so that was a little bit
of a preview.
We're going to see the full Monty now.
So here's actually with a brief history of
modularity.
Give her a round of applause.
ASHLEY: All right.
Here everybody.
This is good.
As you filter in, I'm going to start my talk
a little strange and read to you from the
namesake of this talk, which is Stephen Hawking's
A Brief History of Time.
So this is from chapter one, a picture of
the universe, a well known scientist, once
known -- he described how the Earth orbits
around the sun and how the sun, in turn, orbits
around the center of a vast collection of
star called a galaxy typical at the end of
the lecture a little old lady got up in the
back of the room and said, what you have told
us is rubbish.
The world is a giant plate supported on the
back of a tortoise.
And the scientist gave a reply saying: Well,
what is the tortoise standing on, said the
scientist.
You're very clever, young man, very clever,
old lady, but it's turtles all the way down.
Now you might be wondering that our universe
is some sort of plate and there are turtles
floating in space.
You might think that that's an odd idea but
this talk is going to be the kind of talk
that's going to ask you to look at some of
the concepts that you take for granted and
ask you you think they're true.
Now why on earth would something like that,
with turtles in space have to do with JavaScript.
And, hopefully, by the end of this talk, you'll
have figured it out.
All right.
So, hi, my name is Ashley Williams, as was
introduced.
You may know me from Twitter as @agdubs, and
if you do, I'm very sorry, don't follow.
I'm terrible.
I work at this company that you would npm.
Anybody heard of npm?
And that's where I work as a services engineer.
Shout out to the fact that we've released
npm 5.
Download it.
It's cool.
This talk is not about that.
But if you want to talk about that, find me.
If you're the type of person that watches
slides, and sees a typo, and can't handle
themselves, please submit a PR.
I'm always very happy for them.
So I always like to start my talks saying
I like to think about thinking, particularly
the kind of thinking that happens when people
write code and the point of this talk today
is to maybe get you to also think, at least
about the type of thinking that you do when
you write code.
So to get that thinking started, I'm going
to pose you with this.
I'm not going to give you my answer quite
yet but this is a PR that came into a repo
for a documentation project for a programming
language, and they interested remove the jQuery
dependency by adding 400, and removing 200.
So this comes into play with dependency, and
modularity.
How many people think that this is a really
obvious thing to choose, accepted or not?
All right, good.
This talk's for you!
All right.
So I'm one of these people who has, for a
very long time been a teacher as well as an
engineer and I'd like to say that teaching
is nature's way of letting you know how sloppy
your thinking is.
And over a long period of time of teaching
people Node across the world, some people
in the audience are in these photos, we've
run into some fascinating questions from beginners.
Now, here's one of the more fascinating ones
and this is actually one of student of Steve
Kinney's asked him, how did you get permission
to publish a module on npm.
True question.
Many beginners think that you have to get
permission, that there's an exceptionalism
of being able to publish a package.
But I hope you know that is not the case,
literally anyone can publish a package on
npm.
Now once you get the idea of who can publish,
the next one is how do you decide what goes
inside a module?
So like a proper scientist and wanting to
get the correct answer, I went to Twitter
as I always do, because I was like, hey, what's
your primary motivation for writing, or using
modular code?
Now, I got a huge number of responses.
This is a topic that a lot of people like.
But it was interesting because the responses
were very diverse.
So one of the first sets of responses I got
was that people believed that being able to
write modular code made them more disciplined,
made debugging the code easier, made it easier
to test or document.
Alternatively, some people wrote that they
made their code modular for reuse so that
they could do something in the future in case
their code changed.
I put Bradley on his own slide in a talk about
modularity, you gotta give Bradley a shout-out
for all the work that he's done for ES6 modules,
so if you like ES6 modules, particularly in
Node, you should thank him.
So, of course, it was Twitter, so there were
some shit posts, and they might have been
from some of the conference organizers that
you know, we'll let those be.
But the biggest thing that we got was this
idea of being able to reuse things, and in
particular, reuse things by separating concerns.
Now, lots of people love this term separation
of concerns, to the point that a lot of people
said it exactly in their responses but I thought
it was awful vague that it was so specific
what people were saying, so I tried to push
the question a bit further and I said, okay,
separation of concerns, how do you decide
what the concerns are?
And this really stumped people.
People went from having ones of verbose answers
to going...
uh, intuition mostly?
Said this person.
This person suggested throwing darts, which
is about as scientific you can get, I guess.
Now even one of my JavaScript heroes, Ryan
Haberbeek, who is here as an expert, who wrote
the book I learned JavaScript from, even he
had an answer that, you know what, there are
a lot of practical, and ethical, and even
aesthetic considerations to this question
of how you separate out your code and here's
the punchline, the absolute best answer of
how do you split up your code is people got
mad when I put it all in one file.
So you remember this from the intro that I
was not here for but saw on Twitter, I guess
a lot of people got mad.
But believe it or not, people do get mad in
programming quite a bit and I could see how
if someone put their application all in one
file, there would be a bunch of people grumping
about it.
But looking at the summary of these things
it was it was really interesting because people
didn't have an idea or how or why it was a
module.
However, overwhelmingly everyone thought that
it was good.
No one respond with: Don't modularize your
code.
So we're in this interesting positions where
there's a lot of people who feel very interested
in something but don't have a solid grasp
of why.
So this made me think, okay, we have this
huge batch of stuff, and maybe individually
they all make sense but we don't have a coherent
picture of the world, a bit like this store,
which is a real store outside of Madison Square
Garden in New York City.
I don't know if it capitalizes on all it promises
but I would assume it does.
So this made me think, and I did this classic
Ashley think that other people who might not
know me, might not think a normal person would
do.
They would say, oh, the way that people think
about modularity is the way people think about
time.
You know, people have this really intuitionistic
idea that time passes but no one has any friggin'
idea of how time works.
If you do think you have an idea, you should
find me at the party because I'm really interested.
But yeah, this made me think, I love this
book, A Brief History of Time, and it goes
through and chronicles the history of how
we've been thinking about the universe.
So my goal today is not necessarily to give
you any answers but I do want to talk about
the ways that we think about modularity, and
particularly give us some pointers to get
us in the right direction when we talk about
splitting our code because, fundamentally,
splitting our code is so important and so
critical to our daily lives that it's pretty
unsettling that we haven't really examined
it as closely as I think we should.
So I feel like I'm in a pretty good space
to talk about this because the package ecosystem,
I personally think is JavaScript's picture
of the universe, and working at npm, I'm pretty
close to that ecosystem.
So npm, I've checked this probably a week
ago.
We have 472,000 packages, which puts us about
-- by an -- three times as much as the next
package ecosystem.
So packages and modularity mean a lot to JavaScript
because npm is the largest module repository
in the world.
Potentially, the universe.
I don't know if aliens have package managers.
But I feel like we'd be in the running, all
right?
But what I want to do is ask: Okay.
Why is this the case, right?
Why are we, like, modularize all the things!
Cut my code into pieces.
This is my JavaScript!
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, I had to do a pizza joke.
I had to.
It's late.
Gotta get you guys going!
Anyways.
Now lets get really serious.
This is a proper computer science talk.
So let's, Dijkstra, right, so Dijkstra is
in a unique position that they have to think
in computational hierarchies, the automatic
computer, lol, the automatic computer, haha,
the automatic computer confronts us with a
radical new intellectual challenge that has
no precedent in our history.
So I'm not, like, the biggest fan of computer
science exceptionalism but I definitely think
that he's definitely onto something here.
Modularity is the way, we as programmers,
address this challenge that we need to be
thinking in very, very deep conceptual hierarchies.
All right.
So we know kind of the problem that modularity
is solving but what is modularity?
So, again, to the good sources, let's do a
little Wikipedia.
Modular programming is a software-design technique
that emphasizes separating the functionality
of a program into independent, interchangeable
modules, such that each contains everything
necessary to execute only one aspect of the
desired functionality.
So you may or may not be getting the idea
but I'm a little worried about this one aspect
part of it and that seems to be the clincher
of that definition, all right?
So in JavaScript we have this idea called
the small-modules philosophy.
How many people here have heard of that?
How many people like it?
Interesting.
All right.
So what are the fiercest fighters for the
small-modules philosophy?
And he does it with his actions because he's
probably one of the most prolific publishers
on npm is cindersaurus, and he says, it's
all about containing complexity.
By making small, focused modules, you can
build large, complex systems without having
to know every single detail of how everything
works.
Our short-term memory is finite.
So this doesn't get us terribly closer to
where we should separate things; but it is
certainly suggesting that we have a biological
constraint that's gonna require us to make
small packages so that we're able to actually
understand the thing that we're working on,
all right?
So that's obviously begs the question: How
small is too small?
Now this is a classic critique of packages
on npm.
People love getting upset about this.
The one-line Node modules program.
People don't like these, however, they are
installed constantly, continue to be published
and are some of the absolute most popular
packages on npm.
So you have to ask yourself for all this critique,
why is it that we continue to use them?
Now I can't talk about these one-line Node
modules without talking about, dun-dun-dun
Left Pad.
Warning, if you make jokes about Left Pad
to me, I'll get really upset, okay?
But that being said, I think Left Pad is really
interesting to talk about because it brings
up this idea that at which point are we leveraging
modularity too much.
Because at one time, someone did this package
and it's only 11 lines of code here.
Is it worth it to have a way of abstracting
this code out?
Is this doing us any good?
So I think actually that Left Pad was most
fascinating for me was that people started
getting really aggressive and they suggested
that even the existence of a Left Pad module
meant that we had somehow forgotten how to
program, that using this at all meant that
we were terrible programmers and so I kind
of need a minute here, all right?
This makes me think of this talk, which if
you've seen it, or seen me online, you know
I'm not a fan of.
Which is this idea that there's this real
programmer out there, and if you use any sort
of tools, be it a build process, or a packager,
or anything that contains 11 lines of code,
you're not a web developer and I just have
to say, that's not cool.
Building small, reusable abstractions is the
foundation of literally all computer science.
So did we forget to program when we stopped
writing C, stopped writing assembly, stopped
doing electrical engineering, which I can
only say vaguely because I have no idea what
that would be called.
I assume it has to do with soldering, I don't
know.
But this idea there's no true programmer because
you use tools.
It's the Node true Scotsman fallacy, but I
won't go through with that.
So if you think you're not a programmer because
you use tools, I'll have none of that.
What I will say is that making time for modules
is a great idea because this is what I envision
as the best type of application.
So substack who's also a prolific author on
npm describes this applications this way:
When applications are done well, they're really
the application-specific brackish res do you
that cannot be abstracted away.
All the reusable components s sublimate on
npm where people can use it of the commons.
And if you know me, I'm a big fan of the commons,
but commons are hard and [Inaudible] and it
proves that we can do the commons right.
This is the graph of our weekly downloads.
At this point, npm is averaging 2 billion
downloads a week, which means something about
breaking things into tiny packages is working
well, all right?
So this doesn't necessarily mean that it's
without problems.
So this is an Alex Norris comment and so you
can just read there: I want things to be different.
I want things to be modular!
Oh, no.
All right?
So this is what it comes to, this fantastic
book called John Gald which is about system
semantics which is about how systems work,
but especially about how they fail.
And so he says a complex system that works
is invariably found to have evolved from a
simpler system that worked, a complex system
designed from scratch never works and can
never be patched up to make it work.
You have to start over with a simple system.
And, right now, in the JavaScript ecosystem,
we have a complex system, and this complex
system has been causing us problems.
And so from now on I'm going to talk a little
bit about the problems in modularity.
So Nolan Lawson wrote: The more I modularized
my code, the bigger it gets.
Over 400 milliseconds is being spent walking
my browserified tree.
And so he wrote this really interesting article
called the cost of small modules, and the
subtitle is why one horse-sized JavaScript
duck is faster than a hundred duck-sized JavaScript
horses.
And I said, come on, this is perfect but the
interesting thing he goes into this is a typical
web application has ton of little modules
and the reason it has a ton of little modules
is because this really improves developer
experience, all right?
There's lots of these tools that we take for
prepare for when we push our code into production.
Now, these tools are extremely important because
modularizing code helps us as developers but
it doesn't come without a cost, all right?
So one of the things that he notes in his
article is the fact that even just splitting
our code up into closures, into different
functions is actually costing us a lot of
time at runtime.
So looking at stuff like webpack and Browserify,
and something like roll-up closure which moves
you everything up into a single closure, actually
if you look at these graphs, has a significant
amount of runtime improvement.
There's very little of that orange runtime
when you're maintaining the modularity in
your runtime code versus when you're going
to use something that takes that modularity
and collapses it.
And also, by the way, there's tons of new
ones.
There's a new one that just came out just
a few days ago.
It's pretty neat and it's doing the same thing.
It's collapsing this ability to be able to
modularize our code and be able to collapse
it into one thing because preserving that
modularity actually hurts our users because
I told them that they have to stop publishing
new tools because I'll never finish this talk
and I'll also never finish on time but the
goal here is to say that the use of modularity
has grown to such a scale that web developers
are being confronted with ideas that we've
never anticipated.
Oftentimes when you think about performance
in web development, we think about network
latency.
Obviously, we're like, how long is it going
to take over the network but actually it turns
out that with the number of modules that we
are using across all of the devices that we
have, particularly, low-power devices, low-level
programming concepts are now more relevant
to web developers than ever and we're a little
bit not prepared to understand this.
And so I'd like to say, I for one, welcome
our new compiler transpiler overlords because
we need a way to mitigate the stuff that we
do to improve our developer experience and
not have that cost end up on our end users.
So Rich Harris, I think, says this really
great.
He says: Yes, smaller modules are easier to
write, easier to test, and easier to adhere
to sember.
These are all things that make your life,
as a library author easier.
As we've seen, they come at a cost for others.
So the small-modules philosophy totally benefits
the library writers but it disadvantages application
writers because they have to deal with all
of those tiny pieces when they're putting
something together, and, fundamentally, because
that's extremely difficult, it turns out that
that modularity actually harms end users by
costing them time.
So how did we end up here?
All right?
And I love to quote Thomas Kuhn here who says,
science through models through subsequent
exposure to literature without knowing, or
needing to know the characteristics that have
given these models the status of community
paradigms.
What I'm saying is that it's been a little
inconvenient for us to interrogator why we
love modularity so much.
We see it happening, and the tools keep happening
and this is how we use it.
This is the page of the npm SeigeBot and she's
saying here, your monolith is complex, your
application is complex, but to split it up
to modularize it actually makes it more complex.
So we're kind of complex.
So we're kind of in a pixel here because I'm
saying that modularity makes it easier but
it's also making it harder.
This is some graffiti that I saw in San Francisco,
my solution is probably worse than the problem
so we're now in another oh-no situation.
So this is one of my favorite computer scientists,
Rich Hickey, and I says most of the problems
of computer software are problems of conception
so I want us to be focused on the problems
of day to day work.
So what I'd like to say is that when we think
about programming, software development is
change management.
That's why we have version control, that's
why we have Sember, the hardest fact about
programming is that it changes and this is
actually really interesting because this really
is featured briefly in A Brief History of
Time by Stephen Hawking because he says: It's
an interesting reflection on the characteristic
of thought that no one had suggested that
the universe was expanding or contracting.
Which is to say when we tried to paint a picture
of the universe, they never thought that the
universe would have changed, they just assumed
that it was exactly the way it was.
And I think oftentimes when we think about
breaking up our code, we evaluate it in that
same, static way.
So it turns out that I was, like, I did ask
Twitter how do you modularize.
And I did go to Google Scholar and looked
on how to module and there's an amazing paper
by an author named David Parnus and the paper
is called On the Criteria to be Used on Decomposing
Systems into Modules and it turns out that
he has an answer that nobody provided when
I asked on Twitter.
This is what he said, he said: Start with
a list of difficult design decisions or design
decisions that are likely to change.
Each module is then designed to hide such
a decision from the others.
So here's the trick.
The goal of modularity.
We can always talk about it as making our
lives easier but the truth of the matter we
should be using modularity to solve things
that are hard.
So all of a sudden you might be like, I had
a conception about modularity that aren't
correct, how do I go about computerring.
Richard says, no one is born knowing how to
write software.
I don't even know how to do it right now.
I'm still trying to figure it out.
So you might be in despair.
So this is a have famous existential philosopher,
Jean Paul-Sartre, and he quotes this book,
In Programming in C: Every line of code is
written without reason, maintained out of
weakness, and deleted by chance.
I need some water.
Anyways but based on this level of despair,
what he suggests that we do is we suggest
not only do we write code to help our programs
change, but we should be not focusing on code
that's easy to extend, but, rather, code that
is easy to delete.
He says write code that is easy to delete,
not easy to extend.
Instead of building reusable software, we
should try to build disposable software.
I can't tell you that deleting code is more
fun than writing code.
So we come back to this question of do we
delete this jQuery dependency.
So what I thought was very interesting about
this was there's a lot of questions to ask
about this.
But in the end, using the PR, and accepting
the jQuery dependency is what people thought.
And more than what people saying their feelings
about jQuery, what I do think it indicated
so that we're kind of seeing a return to conservativism
in the way that we are thinking about using
modules and packages in our programming.
For a long time, we were using modules totally
uncritically.
We were doing a lot of work, including lots
of them and we're seeing a lot of people go
the opposite direction now and there's a lot
more of this not invented here.
I'm going to bundle in my code.
And not use a package, all right?
But what I want to say is I think there's
a really amazing challenge here and that instead
of just rejecting the idea of using tons of
modularity, we should be looking for new solutions.
Modularity is an old problem that we're dealing
with but at a brand-new scale that I think
is really exciting.
So I had asked recently a couple of -- a few
months after the first time, why do you choose
to split your code and so one of my coworkers,
Chris Dickinson actually had a really awesome
answer.
He said I have two answers, the first one
is kind of like what I would say, like, academically,
but the other one is actually how I think
I really feel and what he says is: Programming
is like a maze that humans lack the language
to describe completely.
With practice you start to internalize the
maze.
And so that can seem pretty bad and what I
want to say is internalizing and utilizing
intuition isn't super terrible.
It turns out dogs know calculus which is pretty
neat.
You can read about this guy and his corgis
to pick up a ball.
They're actually able to calculate the most
efficient route, they're made of star stuff.
So we can always use intuition to figure out
how to use modularity.
So we can all be a bunch of corgis.
So in summary, modularize your code to make
your life easier for sure but the way that
you modularize, the way that you separate
it out is by isolating things that are hard.
That's how you're going to make your life
easier.
And in fact, modularizing is not free.
It's actually pretty expensive and the consequences
could be for you for other developers and
also as you are end users.
So this helps you -- too many people are are
all like, I don't know what all that fancy
stuff is, I don't need that.
No, they're solving problems that you already
have, so you should be looking into these
tools and using them.
And, finally, this is a fast-moving space
right now, and there's not a lot of definitive
answers and I can't help but know that on
Twitter recently, there's been a lot of really
nasty conversations about this, so I want
to say, quit being jerks on Twitter, all right?
So I think this problem is far from being
solved and I think getting more meet me into
this conversations and critically interrogating
what we think about modularity is super important.
So I'll end with this.
This is from Julia Evans who everyone got
mad at when she put it in one file.
She says: The more programming I do, the more
things I run into, I don't know, Google doesn't
know, my colleagues don't know, but we gotta
do it anyway and when this happens, she says,
right, this is why they pay a human with a
brain who can investigate and learn, and these
should be the problems we're most excited
to solve.
Thank you so much.
This is all of the sources from the talk.
Install npm 5!
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much, Ashley.
That was really amazing.
And before you go, I took a photo of this.
So this store, in New York, that sells karate
hip hop action/drama headphones and luxury.
Have you ever been in this store?
ASHLEY: No, I just stood outside.
I'll come back and let you know.